[Applause]
let's talk about soap and water gloves
and masks hospital beds and respirators
working from home social distancing come
on but in a slum a refugee camp or a war
zone it's just not realistic the virus
does not care about nationality or
ethnicity affection or face hundreds of
millions of people the world's most
vulnerable are at risk because of the
corona virus neglecting them hurts
everybody the worst thing that could
happen is to suppress the disease in
developed countries and let it spread
like fire in the developing world
so how do the world's most vulnerable
people stay safe who's responsibility is
it to help and what happens if we do
nothing
this pandemic is tough we're losing
people we love millions are out of work
most of us are still under lockdown
we're all adjusting but in some parts of
the world the coronavirus will make an
already hard life unimaginably harder
last year the United Nations predicted
that in 2020 more than 168 million
people would be in humanitarian
assistance and that was before Cova 19
they live in a war zone they have fled
one they have survived a natural
disaster they don't have homes they live
in severe poverty these people will now
have to deal with a new threat to their
lives look at Yemen people there have
already endured five years of fighting
the UN says it's the world's worst
humanitarian crisis
24 million Yemenis depend on aid to
survive people are starving nearly all
hospitals have been destroyed clean
water is scarce and a cholera outbreak
has killed thousands most of them
children and then there is a military
blockade led by Saudi Arabia that
prevents supplies from getting in with
coronavirus in the picture doctors have
no idea how they cope I am and I think
his Anaya - I get an Austin I better get
a hustle Nikes at 10:00 for tonight get
me I'm desperate and I'm me I will Hafsa
- son she didn't yet and what about
other places cut off from the world like
the Gaza Strip some thought the blockade
of Palestinian land might protect it
from Cobra 19 the virus still got it
in March Israel sent 200 test kits for
nearly 2 million people and then there
are all the people who've had to leave
their homes because the conflict
disasters are to find a job many now
live in camps the UN thinks there are
about 70 million displaced people around
the world that's roughly the entire
population of the UK and that includes
more than 30 million children in Syria
millions were already displaced because
of the nine-year war and they're still
running
[Music]
fighting in the province of idli over
the last six months alone has forced a
million people to leave everything
behind a population so traumatized by
violence now terrified of a virus health
officials are warning that about 100,000
people could die in Northwest Syria we
want one empty ventilator ready to
receive corona patient the lack of
resources is a huge problem for
displaced people everywhere and when it
comes to fighting disease the other
problem is a complete lack of space try
applying social distancing in the
world's biggest refugee camp
[Music]
close to a million bur hinga refugees
live here they escaped a military
crackdown in Myanmar they've escaped
persecution they've escaped violence and
now they have this this invisible threat
around them unlike any that they've seen
before the unsanitary and cramped
conditions there have already led to
operates of diphtheria and measles the
same could happen with kovat 19 we've
seen how this virus has spread on cruise
ships even in luxury situations imagine
how fast that disease will spread in a
camp where people are pushed together
the International Rescue Committee did
the numbers on the diamond princess
which was quarantined in Japan 712
people got infected with the corona
virus that's out of 3,700 passengers and
crew many of them had their own rooms
the IRC then compared that to the camp
from rahaga refugees in Cox's Bazar they
calculated that the population density
there is one and a half times higher
than on the cruise ship in Greece's
biggest refugee camp it's eight times
more crowded knowing that and how
contagious the coronaviruses it's a real
concern keeping people apart is probably
the single most effective protection
measure but for so many people it's just
not an option and crowding isn't just a
problem in camps most refugees don't
live in camps they live in cities
crowded cities that often have poor
sanitation poor services also a lot of
people who are not refugees live in
really really poor conditions in cities
so we need to worry about places where
health systems are extremely weak
places like Venezuela and Zimbabwe where
their economies have collapsed and so
have their healthcare systems
countries in the Horn of Africa dealing
with drought famine and even a plague of
locusts and so many other nations
already coping with diseases natural
disasters were really high rates of
poverty
[Music]
so what do we do one UN body says
developing countries need a crisis
package worth two and a half trillion
dollars Lauren's also launched an appeal
for a two billion dollar global
humanitarian response the IMF and World
Bank have pledged sixty two billion
dollars in loans for low-income
countries and there's growing pressure
on the g20 the world's richest nations
to relieve debt owed by poor nations and
to share some of their wealth what is
needed is a large-scale coordinated and
comprehensive multilateral response
amounting to at least ten percent of
global GDP ten percent of global GDP is
a staggering amount of money you're
looking at at least eight trillion
dollars to save lives and protect
economies from collapsing and to put
that in context it's roughly the size of
Germany and Japan's economies combined
but the experts say that to fight
epidemics a properly funded global
response works
the world pledged millions of dollars
and came together to fight the spread of
HIV malaria and more recently Ebola at
the height of the Ebola outbreak in
Congo we were tracking and tracing and
visiting 25,000 contacts every day in
the middle of a shooting war so it is
possible to carry out a large-scale
public health interventions even in the
most extreme of circumstances remember
the 168 million people the UN said need
aid around the world while stepping in
when kovat 19 reaches them isn't just
about avoiding unimaginable misery it's
about protecting everyone because if we
don't step in the experts say the
coronavirus will circle back around and
affect our health and our economies all
over again it would be a smart strategy
for every developed country just to
spend a little bit of their money on
dealing with this problem in the most
vulnerable places as well let us
remember that we are only as strong as
the weakest health system you know
interconnected world's the point they're
making is it's a pandemic its global so
we have to fight it together we don't
know when we'll be back on the start
here set but not to worry we're still
going to be bringing you more episodes
any way we can in the meantime our
website aljazeera.com has all the latest
on the corona virus
I'll see you next week
[Music]